youtube um did this video for coach frog
great friend of mine love him met him
coming up in the vayner sports game this
is just me with a bunch of
alpha youngsters
who i love with all my heart you know
genuinely
six of the kids that watched this talk
are gonna play in national footballing
or the nba like those kind of kids so
catching them in this sage group um i
just really hope that one of them got it
and more importantly the reason we're
putting out this content
if you've got a seven to fourteen year
old super athlete in your family let
them watch this i i think it can help
now listen stars crew i'm really really
excited to be with you all i mean look
in this short period of time i always
love doing this i love this program
i love what all of you represent i i
love where your minds are at at this
point
i guess
what i really would love to do is kind
of kick it for a couple minutes but frog
i would love for us to do some q a too
with the guys because i want to know
what's really on their mind specifically
for the two or three that got the
courage to raise their hand and go for
it so let me chop for a few minutes and
then we'll go into it
the there's two things that are really
running through my mind
if you're in this program there's two
avenues that i really want to talk about
one
you make it to the league
two you don't
right because that's going to be the
binary outcome right
and so
life is crazy because it's just about
this
there really is nothing else
it's life is how you see it
some of you in this room are optimistic
and some of you are pessimistic that's
just real talk it's just the chemicals
in your body some of you are approached
with any situation and you're like this
is gonna be great and others in this
room see a situation and they're
thinking about why this isn't gonna work
out
and for me what i've been spending my
whole life on starting with my sister
who's three and a half years younger
that i tried to reshape
and and see more positivity in every
outcome to where i am today where i get
10 000 dms a day on tick tock and
instagram about this talk even though
they think they're talking about
something else it's the same [ __ ] which
is
if i can get to you at this point and
you actually realize while you watch
this video right now me talking with you
that
you're actually in charge
like on some real [ __ ] you're actually
in charge of deciding if you want to see
the opportunity or if you want to see
what's not going to be the opportunity
the second you make that switch it's
game over and i'll give you the comp
for some of you this is going to make
sense
everybody in this room is so talented
that at some point now that you're at
this level this age
some of you are starting to realize
oh wait if i really work
right because you've been so talented
you are so talented
that
some of you and i see coach shake in his
head like you know it's this is a big
one and it's the physical version and
then i want to get you into the mental
version the physical version is some of
you in the last six to 24 months were
like wait a minute
if i actually go a little harder if i
actually push myself if i actually work
well i'm starting to get better than
dude that was better than me a month ago
like because talent
is just half of the equation
there's a bunch of people in this room
that are way more talented than the dude
that's sitting to the left and right of
them and that's going to be the way it
is forever and the dude to the left and
right of them are going to be in the
league and you're not
and forget about injuries and other [ __ ]
because that's some other [ __ ] i'm
talking this
is this single variable of that of what
i just said
and so for me
anytime i get a quick burst with the
youngsters that i'm going to look up to
in a couple years because let there be
no confusion
in two minutes life goes fast
frog we're getting old in two minutes
these kids are gonna be shining on
saturdays and sundays
and we're gonna be cheering for them
i just really want you to win
you know
one one thing that i was really affected
about when i was a kid roughly around
your ages i would start i don't know why
like almost like an old wisdom thing i
would just chop it up with old people
like when i was like
9 12 14 17 i would just at the
playground i would just roll up on
grandparents and chop up with them and
the one thing that scared me was regret
people would always just have regret
like i wish i did i wish i married this
girl or i wish i got that job and
because i love sports so much it would
really catch my attention when people
were like man i wish i kept pursuing my
baseball career i think i could have
made it
what i'm petrified on some real talk
with all of you right now is you can't
be in this room right now unless you're
bananas talented
which actually means one of two extremes
you're either gonna go there and you're
gonna live that life and it's gonna be
remarkable on that level
or
you're gonna live with regret at 25 29
37 42
57 and the worst thing in the world
besides
not having life death all that terrible
[ __ ] is really regret and i'm just
trying
to pump fire into this screen for 15
minutes to get one of you if i can get
one of you
to hear what the [ __ ] i'm actually
saying and decide to switch it up and
not and this is the [ __ ] moment where
you decided not to go down the path of
ending up with regret but actually doing
it whether you win in sports or not it's
more about the mindset of just happiness
like being good
that's what i'm here for that's really
what i'm trying to accomplish in these
15 minutes like please please choose
like the same way you work on watching
film
and going into the weight room
and like your craft running sharper
routes or working on
swim moves or whatever [ __ ] position you
got like the same way you work on that
you need to work on being like man i'm
not going to let [ __ ] insecurity
worrying about what other people think
negativity just tune that [ __ ] out grab
both of your index fingers and put them
directly in your ears and live like that
for the rest of the
time on your earth because i'll tell you
why here's how it plays out if you do
this because that's how i play and when
i see everybody else who's winning aka
happy comma successful they got [ __ ]
index fingers in their ears
index and let me tell you why that
matters
this is i use a sports analogy
everywhere else this is literal for
y'all when you do this
you don't hear them booing
you're not worried about putting up an
instagram video and people saying you're
too slow or that's whack or who gives it
you can't hear them
that's powerful because everyone gets
wrecked on some hate and trolling
that's not even the biggest thing i'm
trying to get you to protect yourself
from when you do this this is the big
one boys
you can't hear them cheering
some of y'all are gonna lose on the
mission that you have for yourself right
now because you're gonna get high on
your own supply
you're gonna believe what they say about
you you're gonna believe those five
stars you're gonna believe you're number
seven and it's gonna soften you and
you're gonna lose
you're gonna get so hyped on all the
gassing that you're gonna [ __ ] it up
and so what i'm trying to do right here
is get you into this place
this place
[ __ ] love your friends family be the
be a good person do the right [ __ ] put
in the work love yourself first you're
not gonna love anybody else if you don't
love yourself first if you're sitting
right now and you're insecure and you
don't love yourself because there's a
lot of people like that so there's
definitely people in this room i promise
you somebody else put that poison in
your head
parent neighbor older sibling somebody
else put that poison in your head
love yourself first then you can love
everybody else put in the mental work
you've got the physical talents that's a
wrap god gave you that that's a wrap
that you've got that that is not even an
interesting conversation you've got that
everybody's going to lose on this
everybody loses on this and you got a
real shot a real shot not to because you
got people around you this is why i [ __ ]
with this program it's why i'm here that
really care and i really i pray that one
person heard me right now that was
starting the process of letting this go
down the wrong path it's about loving
yourself but not feeling yourself love
yourself but don't think you're special
i think i'm the best i actually think
i'm currently in the process of becoming
the greatest entrepreneur of all time
meanwhile i don't think i mean [ __ ] if i
die tomorrow i'll be trending on social
media for 24 hours a little love your
favorite clip you're this you guys be
like damn we just talked to him
yesterday you know like that and then
that'd be it and that'd be it
so believe in your [ __ ] but don't gass
yourself up to take you off course
that's what i got to say frog
so on on on that theme on that theme
i would love to answer a question or two
in detail for some of the people like
who thought something and what question
do they have
oh wait go ahead miguel go ahead i'll
kick it off uh
gary miguel bennett i'm director of
basketball here at stars prep uh
appreciate you um
can you give can you share with us with
these guys like the top like your top
three point of emphasis for
having a
successful mindset i got you then and
this is clear for me because you know i
got gray hairs boys now like i've been
living it now i'm 46 now now i feel i
felt this at 16 but i know it at 46.
number one
accountability
this is gonna set you free whether it's
true or not in every situation
if you always know that it's always your
fault
it sounds crazy but that will keep you
crazy happy the amount of athletes i've
met that blame coaches even at the
professional level
blows my mind there are dudes in this
room who always are talking [ __ ] blaming
coach
right now
i see some of these good looking faces i
know behind that face i'm like that kid
right there you know like like it's real
do not blame anybody but yourself
it will make you happy it's a huge
mindset number two i am blown away by
people's entitlement just because your
mom and dad had sex at the right exact
second to give you athletic ability
doesn't mean nobody owes you [ __ ] so
accountability eliminating first
accountability second eliminating
entitlement nothing is owed to any of
y'all it is what it is it's like sports
it's a game
so just because somebody gave you a
scholarship or gave you an at-bat it's
you
you're not owed anything
coach if you've got real accountability
like this is on me and you don't think
anybody else owes you [ __ ] the last one
is in a different school but all
together those three change people's
lives the third one is simple which is
be nice this is a crazy one especially
at this age if you realize how life
actually plays out and you will one day
when you're 60 70 80
the number one hack
the the smartest move
be kind which is why coach earlier i
said be nice to yourself because
nobody's nice to anybody else if they
don't like themselves the only people in
here that are mean trying to tear down
others because they're hurting when
people are tearing down other people
that just exposes that they're hurt but
if you're lucky enough to feeling good
give roses to people because people are
going to be the fuel that gets you there
that's my mindset game coach uh what do
you think separates what do you think
separates you from other entrepreneurs
whoa
that's a good question okay g eat it up
then
i think most entrepreneurs are driven by
money
and they don't share their best thoughts
with everybody else because that's how
they think they get money i think i'm
the most generous communicative
entrepreneur that's a beast in the world
and that's why i think i'm different i'm
trying to get i'm trying to get
everybody else to get paid and be happy
and win too cause here's the here's the
craziest part back to how you guys roll
i'm competitive as [ __ ]
but let there be no confusion you're
never stopping jake any other a player
anyway and the world is abundant if
you're eaten that's not taken out of my
food i'm too [ __ ] good i'm gonna eat
what do you think separates great
players from good players like their
mindset
here's a funny one i actually think and
i've been really paying it i love this
question but i think it comes down to
who loves it the most like actually
likes it there's definitely kids that
i'm looking at right now that realize
logically like this is how i'm gonna get
paid but they don't like live for it
you don't live for ball and i think the
the like the the all-pro versus the hall
of famer the hall of famer is addicted
they cry when they retire
they're trying to play to the last day
right even if look at the greats they
can't even retire muhammad ali michael
jordan
tom brady even though i hate tom brady
michael jordan so much they are the
[ __ ] greats these [ __ ] don't know
how to retire they unretire they are
tired because they [ __ ] love it too
much so the separation is the [ __ ]
passion for it you can't breathe without
it and by the way the kids in here like
when everyone else is like you know like
you love it too much or like have some
other hobbies like don't let somebody
else tell you what you [ __ ] love look
at this [ __ ] you won't be able to see it
this is my [ __ ] report card from high
school i failed every [ __ ] class
right like like i like and everyone's
like no no you need a [ __ ] diploma to
fall back on we know you're telling your
whole high school gary that you're going
to be the best businessman don't let
anybody tell you what your passion is
right now sports is hard the chances and
the likelihood of this room being there
is going to be hard real hard
but just falling like falling in love
with falling in love with something you
can take that energy and put it to
something else don't let people tell you
what you love or how hard you go squeeze
the [ __ ] out of this opportunity how do
you keep mentally strong
people are trying to tear you down
by feeling bad for them
on some real on some real [ __ ] could you
imagine living a life where you're
actually interested
in making somebody else feel bad the
[ __ ] is that
[Music]
you know i i swear to god i heard that
speaker just go on and i
frog i swear to god i hated school so
much that hairs just went up back in my
neck like thank god i don't thank god i
don't hear that [ __ ] no more
you know no but listen this is a big one
because a lot of you all of you are
gonna get this because i hope you all
stay healthy and stay motivated and you
get to that place you guys are all
getting close to where you're gonna get
a lot of internet love right you guys
aren't far away from getting that gas
just remember this i hope you remember
this
somebody taking time out of their day
to leave a comment to try to hurt your
feelings
feel bad for those people not on some
like like egotistical [ __ ] actually be a
human being and be compassionate
understand how much that person's life
isn't happy that they need to go make
somebody else unhappy to be on some
misery loves company [ __ ] if you were to
tell your 15 year old self one thing
right now right before he goes out for
the two more months before he goes to
his freshman year in high school what is
it i would look that boy dead in the
face and i said i would literally tell
him
you're gonna be right talk that talk boy
that's what i'm talking about for every
one of you that thinks you're special
and you're going there you're right just
follow that through you guys have one
thing that's really hard that i didn't
have
injuries were not gonna not make me the
best entrepreneur of all time that will
happen to some of y'all which is why i
want to get your mind right because the
day you have to face that after you
think you're going to the hall of fame
and you need to convert that into being
public servant a politician a teacher a
coach an entrepreneur that's going to be
a tough transition i got goose i don't
know if you guys see this right now like
i can feel this is a big piece of advice
for some i feel it for there's for one
of you this is going to matter
my 15 year old self i would have looked
at a little young by the way when i was
15 i looked nine and i would look that
boy in the face and say you're right
because at 15 i'm like i'm gonna tear
the world apart as an entrepreneur and
that wasn't even a thing back then i
didn't even use the word entrepreneur i
said businessman because we didn't have
that word yet
for the ones that really hit with what i
just said because they they're gonna
like when they're brushing their teeth
tonight they're like i'm going i'm going
it's me i'm that guy
the one thing you all got that i didn't
have is an acl injury
back to back back injuries like stuff
that's real and that's unfortunate and
you you've got to resonate with that sam
bowie was a beast that's why he got
drafted before michael jordan a beast
but that knee didn't hold up and that's
going to be the fate of some of y'all
but if you get this right
if you get this right
you'll be able to convert that energy
and maybe build a 100 million dollar
business or become a pastor or become a
teacher or net or help 13 kids become
hall of famers you got to get this right
kids you got to get this right
appreciate you
[Applause]
[Music]
you